yes that's right we're all expecting an
online only apple april event
sometime this month which is definitely
weird since apple usually has an event
in march
but that obviously didn't happen even
though
so many people were so sure that we'd
have one on march
23rd and eyebrows were shaved because of
it but thankfully
more and more puzzle pieces are coming
together so we're now
almost 100 sure that we're getting an
apple april event
so what i'm going to do in this video is
go through all of the leaks and rumors
that discuss
new apple products and let you know
which ones you should be expecting
and which ones you shouldn't so let's
get right into it the first thing i want
to talk about are the major points of
evidence for why we're getting an april
event
and it all coincides with the new 2021
ipad pro
which didn't end up shipping in march
like many expected it too
a couple months back in january we got
some leaked dimensions and cad
files for the ipad pro which shows that
it's going to be released
very soon since this type of stuff
doesn't leak unless the product is
almost ready to go
then a month later mark german who is an
incredibly reliable leaker
said that the ipad pro is going to be as
powerful as the
m1 max and this totally makes sense
since we're expecting the ipad pro to
get the a14x
chip with 8 cpu cores and 8 graphics
cores
and just a couple of weeks ago 925 mac
discovered mentions of the a14x chip
within ios 14.5 beta code
and this usually only happens right
before a product is released
for example beta code mentioning the new
m1 max
leaked just a couple of weeks before
apple officially announced them in
november of last year and since ios 14.5
is expected to release sometime within
the next month
it perfectly matches up to the ipad pro
releasing at an april event
and to make it even better 95 mac found
that the a14x is based on
the t8 103 which is the code name for
the
m1 chip so the two chips will likely be
very similar
and going even further digitimes
reported that volume
shipments of the new ipad pro will begin
in the second
quarter of 2021 which we are in now
we then got a bombshell leak from mark
german
claiming that the new ipad pro will come
with a mini led display
on the 12.9 inch model only upgraded
cameras
the a14x chip a usbc port with
thunderbolt
functionality and he said that it should
be coming
in april and since he's one of the most
reliable leakers
we can basically bank on this some of
those features like the a14x chip
the thunderbolt port and the mini led
display are a
huge deal so apple will absolutely want
to show it off
during an event so an april event is
extremely
likely to happen and john prosser is
also
banking on april for the event date
and finally here's one more big piece of
evidence
from weibo user uncle pan somehow he got
a hold of a sticker
showing that a new unreleased accessory
is coming soon which supports the first
second and third generation 11 inch ipad
pro
and the thing is the 3rd gen model
doesn't exist yet
it's the one that we're expecting later
this month
and uncle pan mentioned that the new
ipad pro is coming in mid
april so there's more confirmation now
if you're wondering which accessory this
could end up being
well i did some research and i think i
know what to expect
i found the box to the ipad pro magic
keyboard case
and the sticker looks almost identical
from the format to the layout
in the various languages so this
accessory is
almost certainly an official apple
product
and i personally believe that it's a new
second generation
magic keyboard case for a couple of
different reasons
first off we've been hearing rumors that
it should be coming alongside the new
ipad pro
which was supposed to be released at the
march event that never
happened so april makes sense for a
release date
and if you're wondering how apple could
possibly upgrade the magic keyboard
they actually applied for a patent
specifically for a new magic keyboard
case almost a year ago
the images show a slot in the hinge for
the apple pencil too
and apparently it'll also wirelessly
charge the apple pencil
at the same time making it the perfect
solution
now getting into the next image it shows
a completely
new hinge system essentially allowing
you to raise the ipad pro
much higher if you'd like to or even use
it in a new
clipboard mode which will finally solve
the problem people had with the other
magic keyboard
where you couldn't lay down the ipad pro
to write and draw
so in my opinion if we're getting a new
ipad pro this month
then we're for sure getting a new magic
keyboard case alongside
it now if you put all of the puzzle
pieces together
with the crazy powerful a14x chip as
well as the new 5g support that we're
also expecting
it makes a lot of sense for the ipad pro
to finally support professional mac apps
like final cut logic and xcode which has
been rumored for some time now
by john prosser so if they announced
this
it's probably going to come either
sometime this month or
later at apple's wwc event in june
and now with the ipad pro and magic
keyboard out of the way
let's move on to another product we're
expecting to come
at this event and that's of course the
new air tags
which have been rumored for a very long
time they're basically going to be small
little trackers that you can buy
activate and place onto or into anything
you'd like to track
within the find my app so that way
you can keep track of your keys your
backpack or
anything else that you can think of and
since they'll be coming with the
ultra wide band chip built in you'll be
able to open up an augmented reality
view
in your find my app and literally see
your air tag
through objects like inside of your
couch just using your iphone
the battery life is going to be
excellent at least a full year or two
and the best part is that air tags will
probably have wireless charging since
we've seen so many leaks and rumors
pointing to that feature coming and the
way it's gonna work
is incredibly simple you just put the
air tag on the back of your iphone 12
or newer for half an hour and then it's
fully charged
because i don't know if you know this or
not but the latest iphone 12
secretly supports reverse wireless
charging
for accessories apple never mentioned
this
because they probably were gonna release
the air tags alongside the new iphone
but the air tags were of course delayed
over and over again now on top of that
recent leaks and rumors are pointing to
it being smaller than expected
being just a bit larger than a quarter
but around six millimeters thick
and according to max wine back they'll
retail for around
39 each but on the flip side
we did have some earlier rumors from
left to dream
that pointed to them having two
different sizes so it's gonna be
interesting to see how this plays out
but either way
expect air tags at apple's april event
later this month
now let's move on to the one product
that's probably coming at the april
event
but there's a chance that it won't for a
couple of different reasons
and yes i'm talking about the rumored
24-inch
fully redesigned apple silicon imac last
month
john prosser tweeted that the imac is
ready to launch at any time
and on top of that a new apple silicon
imac was leaked in an
xcode crash log pointing to apple
already testing out the model
on the latest mac os software and to add
even more evidence
john revealed that the new imac will be
coming in some brand new colors
and coincidentally almost all of those
colors
perfectly match up to the new apple
spring colors
that uncle pan revealed for some new
apple
cases and according to max weinbach we
should be expecting some new seasonal
apple watch bands probably with the same
spring colors
and that's exactly what love to dream
tweeted new colorful apple watch bands
but the crazy thing is that the tweet
was actually a reply
to a question about the new imac so he
agrees with that as well
so it's all starting to look like apple
could have a spring
color themed event to reveal the new
imac
and then left to dream apparently also
tweeted out that the new imac screen
is really big bigger than the biggest
one
which of course is referring to the
27-inch imac
replacement so everything is really
starting to add up
but i just have a couple of doubts i
personally don't think that the larger
imac is ready to go
just yet since it needs to come packed
with a ton of
power and i don't think that apple is
ready to reveal
the faster m1x chip so based on that
the larger imac might not come until
later this year
and here's where the problem comes in
for this smaller 24 inch imac
if the m1x chip isn't ready yet then
that means that the smaller imac
is only going to come with the same m1
chip
that we already have and while that'll
still make
for a great imac fully redesigned for
around 1100
to 1300 dollars it's probably going to
disappoint some people
if it does not come with an m1x chip
upgrade option
now on the other hand apple could
totally surprise
everyone by announcing that m1x chip
but then it would make sense to also
release the larger imac at the same time
but i just don't think that it's ready
yet so this is definitely a toss-up
so we're just gonna have to wait and see
and now let's get into the
maybe section starting off with new
airpods
yes we've had various leaks and rumors
pointing to the airpods 3 being delayed
until later this year
but out of nowhere a new leaker uncle
pan
came out and said that we should be
expecting new airpods at
this april event alongside the ipad pro
and new accessories
so i don't know if that means that it
could be a new set of airpods pro and
then the airpods 3 are coming later
i don't know we're just gonna have to
wait and see now next
up is of course a new apple tv
a lot of people are expecting this to
come for sure
this month but i have a couple of
reasons to doubt that
first off the current models of the
apple tv especially the 4k model
they're perfectly fine for streaming
video so the only way it would make
sense for them to release a new apple tv
is if they go all out in terms of the
performance
and focus completely on the gaming
market
this makes total sense because we've
been seeing leaks and rumors of apple
working on a gaming specific controller
for many months now and the a14x chip
that we're expecting in the ipad pro
would be perfect for the apple tv
so why not release them at the same time
however
here is where the doubts come in last
month apple released a huge wave
of new apple tv trailers and teasers
and just a few days ago they released a
massive amount
of apple arcade gaming content
right out of the blue so if they were
planning to release a new apple tv this
month
it would have made sense to hold off on
at least the new gaming
push until the actual event to create
more hype so it seems like they are
delaying the new apple tv
until later this year and that actually
matches up to a rumor we got from the
verifier
saying that the apple tv is not gonna
happen until the fourth quarter of this
year
but i personally think that it makes
sense to release it at apple's september
event
since that's where apple released the
last two versions of the apple tv but i
guess that anything can happen
and they may just release it this month
so we're just gonna have to wait now
moving on to more
maybe products we have the new ipad mini
which has been rumored for some time now
according to uncle pan the full screen
ipad mini is
out of play for this month's event and
that fully matches up to a rumor from
kong the most reliable leaker out there
who said that the redesigned ipad mini
is currently
in early development specifically in the
design
stage so it's nowhere near ready to
launch
now this is interesting because it's
been over two years since the ipad mini
has been updated
so it's definitely due for a new model
and if they maybe
just maybe update it this month it'll
likely have the same
old design but with an updated a14 chip
that we already have in the ipad air but
then again
apple's ipad mini 4 went unchanged
for over three and a half years before
the mini 5 came out
so apple could easily just do the same
thing and
hold off until they give the mini a full
redesign
and then that way they're gonna be
giving the brand new ipad pro models
their full attention at this month's
event so i guess we're just gonna have
to wait and see
and now let's finish off with a couple
of products that i'm almost 100
sure will not be released at this
month's event we shouldn't expect
any more macbooks at all since the ones
coming up next are going to be the 14
and 16 inch macbook pros
and the production of those is
apparently delayed until the second half
of 2021
so don't count on seeing those until
maybe the end of summer or fall
and then finally there's the new iphone
se3
and all of the recent rumors are
pointing to it coming next year
so don't count on that either there you
guys go that's what you should and
shouldn't expect
at this month's april event hopefully
you enjoy this video
and if you're excited for those products
coming later this month definitely click
the circle above to subscribe
because we're gonna be getting our hands
on them and testing them
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video